well what's up well hey what's going on
guys
let's go we got audio we gotta have fun
my guy is ready he said fourth quarter
will give us a little four fingers in
the air for the fourth quarter
let's go will's been saying the entire
like all summer long he said listen
shocktober supply squeeze ready to rock
and roll all right buddy you ready to go
always all right let's start first with
uh what what's going on uh in terms of
sopra sopra me and will hung out all
summer we had a sopra summer what uh
what's going on there
yeah so soper looks at the profit-taking
uh or i'm sorry the the state of profit
that the market is holding on any given
day so you're taking a ratio of all the
coins trading in profit all the coins
trading in loss and you get super and
then here we look at a super which is
adjusting for all the outputs below an
hour
and then we're also
doing a seven-day moving average on this
so we're looking at essentially the
weekly version of soper um and so as you
can see recently that we've just bounced
off one you know obviously that's a good
sign so far but we want to see um
obviously an uptrend in the ratio but at
least you know at the minimum um some
stabilization above one
um you know in in bearish markets you
fade the the retests of one and then in
a in a bullish trend uh you know in a
broader bullish trend
you buy the dips along one um and so if
we are in a broader bullish trend which
i personally believe we are but
it's up to you for to to decide
um all these retests of one will become
you know good off buy opportunities
if if you're correct about that
assumption so
we just bounced off of it you know once
again want to see some stabilization uh
but preferably you know increase in the
ratio
i definitely think we're in a bull
market i think you do as well so it's
great to see it bouncing off of off that
one tell us what's going on with the
whales we've got this chart that filters
out all of the kind of exchanges and
known entities uh but explain to us
what's going on here with this whale
chart
yeah so this is just looking at all the
entity flows so the green line we have
whales this is filter out for exchanges
grayscale qbtc
the purpose etf then we have a couple
different lines here we have the shrimps
the crabs the fish octopus so it's just
saying all these different size cohorts
and so what you see is um the high level
you know takeaway is that every uh
single cohort is accumulating right now
as of the last three weeks when you
started to see
the 100 to 1000 btc guys start to buy as
well so right now you have every single
cohort uh accumulating which is which is
pretty remarkable you know when you go
back and
look at times where you see all cohorts
accumulating in unison uh that's that's
historically you know been a pretty good
time to to average and supplies i don't
have a chart of that up here but i have
put that on my twitter in the past it's
happened a couple times before and so
you ask you know where are these coins
coming from
and the answer is exchanges right we
keep talking about how coins are moving
off exchanges
in the last week you have
2869 btc moved off exchanges um which is
about
134 million dollars i think i used a 47k
btc price for that
and they're also down 62
251 btc in the last month which is about
3.2 billion dollars
and so this this leads us to the next
chart um you know you see that that
purple line is the exchange split shock
ratio so comparing all the coins on
exchanges to off blue line we talked
about this a lot the liquid supply ratio
you're comparing um the strong hands to
the weak hands essentially so the
entities that statistically sell a lot
the entities that's this the bit rarely
sell right
and so we have another bullish
divergence when you you know look at
both ratios in comparison to price price
is kind of bleeding sideways bearish
well i put this out i created this last
night so as of this morning maybe that's
starting to change
and then you know this was the same
thing that happened in the summer we
were tracking so um those are the supply
dynamics the one thing i wanted to i
wanted to touch on was just the um the
bids i think this is like important for
people to to keep in mind um it's the
second chart
so what you're looking at here is all
the it's just a heat map of all the biff
and x orders uh the all the bids and
asks on the order book
and so what you see is we have this huge
floor below us
and so
you you can look at this two ways um the
bullish case is obviously like okay the
the chinese bull whales have just set
this concrete floor um
and you know you have started to see
started to see some of those orders
filling the other day uh but the the
perhaps more nuanced view and i'm not
saying this this is the case i'm just
saying keep this in mind um the bearish
case would be that these walls sometimes
are used to generate liquidity to uh
either enter or exit position so you can
you could set a huge wall of bids right
and then whenever the you know the
retail guys start to see price you know
bleeding down into that wall or or floor
i should say
they're going to try to front run that
because they see ho there's this huge
wall like no one's going to sell into
that so i'm going to start selling or
closing my shorts above that on the
other end
or i'm sorry closing my lungs above that
on the other end um you could have that
entity that set the set the floor
actually using that liquidity to exit
the market and then conversely if they
set a giant wall of asks you know it
could be them actually trying to enter
into the market they're basically
putting a cap on the price
everyone is is trying to front run that
wall and sells into that or closes you
know closes their lungs or open shorts
uh like front running that wall and on
the other end of that are actually uh
the same entities that or entity that
created that wall
or or ceiling um are actually in in the
market you know getting long so
you you
you know there's there's nuance to it um
but as i mentioned like the other day
you have started to see some of these
these bids fill um going back though
like
biff and x
activity i could say um has has been
pretty influential on the price like you
see them cap price a lot and set the
floor often times uh it's just you know
keep an eye on it because if you just
see the floor get rugged then you know
that's that's not a good sign
one of the things that i really like
that you're doing right now is not only
are you looking at metrics that uh david
poyle willie wu and many other folks uh
kind of before you uh have created and
spent a bunch of time uh on but you're
also creating a bunch of new metrics as
well and one of them that you included
in the newsletter uh this week was this
idea of a delta valuation model and
trying to determine like this floor idea
explain exactly what you're trying to
get at with the metric and then show us
what it's uh kind of highlighting today
sure so
last week we looked at the liquid supply
floor and so that was looking at
basically an estimate of the real-time
floor that long-term investors or strong
hands have set
this is uh a bit more conservative in
the in the sense that the floor has
never been broken whereas the model last
week it's been broken briefly twice
this is looking at um
where should i start so delta cap is the
difference between and this was
conceptualized by david poi delta cap is
the difference between the average cap
so the all-time moving average cap
in realized cap and realize cap is
basically an on-chain view op so it's
it's looking at the last time coins were
last move and creating a capitalization
based off of that so for example um you
know let's say i'm roger vayer i bought
bitcoin at a dollar about 100 000 btc at
a dollar
right and i've never moved them you know
in market cap that that chunk of coins
right is worth four uh 4.7 billion
dollars i hope i just did that public
math correctly and then
if he has it if he hasn't moved those
coins it's only adding a hundred
thousand dollars uh to realize cap and
so you're it's it's basically giving you
this average uh pri or price or
capitalization you know you just divide
the cap by the circulating supply to get
the to get realized price but you're
looking at this average capitalization
based off of where these investors have
bought into the market
and so taking the difference of that is
what delta cap is and that's giving you
as you'll see by these little green
circles
is giving you these these good buy zones
especially just saying you know okay
we're getting close to the to delta cap
that's probably a good time to average
in some heavier buys or you can
statistically take riskier buys right
because the asymmetry of of the market
at that time is heavily skewed to the
upside because we're very close to
what's historically been the floor
and so then you take a multiple of that
and you get the delta cap top and so
that's that purple line it's just
multiplying it by a special number
seven and a half which is completely
arbitrary i just played around with it
until it fit
and so you see that that that's caught
some of the tops as well and then you
just take both of those divide by two
which just taking the mean of it and you
get that little middle uh the middle uh
blue line and that's there's been you
know historically a
you know level that price has interacted
pretty pretty nicely with like you look
at 2019 that's where it bounced off of
in that little mini uh bull run
um so yeah that that's the model it's
just nothing crazy um it's just you know
you can use that in confluence with the
liquid supply floor and you know this is
like a a much more conservative uh floor
that because you know once again it's
never been broken um you know we also
have shown before i think the pricing
models using like uh willy's top model
which is at like 190k that's using an
all-time moving average of bitcoin um
i've also seen pricing similar pricing
models using thermo cap which is uh the
security spend of miners so there's
different ways right you can you can
kind of create these valuation models
but it's interesting like you know
this is all based off of the the on the
unchain activity and um you know we can
kind of create these valuation methods
for bitcoin where we don't have like
discount cash flows or anything like
that
when we look at the bitcoin number of
active entities uh it feels like this
has been really lockstep with uh bitcoin
price uh but we're starting to see kind
of an increase uh over the last couple
of days and weeks
right yeah like i think the the one
bearish case you could make from an
on-chain perspective is just looking at
some of the transactional activity
excuse me um so you look at transaction
count um you know the mempool overall
volume active entities
also net entities growth which is the
difference between um you know the new
entities coming on chain and the ones
leaving and basically you know some of
these things are showing that there's
low demand to use the network um
although we have seen as you mentioned
uh you know uptick recently but you know
from a broader standpoint we still are
historically you know lower than where
we have have been in in you know bull
market uptrends but i think you can make
an argument a counter argument to this
and say three things um first of all
that the speculative market participants
are gone so we're seeing like
transaction volume is dominated by these
larger guys so we're looking at like
volume of 10 million dollars and up has
seen a very large increase over the last
few weeks and it's just completely
dominating all the volume on every given
day
also another another culprit could be
batching done by exchanges so i know a
couple guys who work with exchanges and
um
i guess now over you know over the last
couple months they've started to utilize
batching more to save the money and and
i guess it just saves them hassle as
well
and then lastly uh and this is probably
the more popular answer with bitcoiners
but i think it's honestly the the
least effective of the three um on the
lack of transactional activity and
that's transactions migrating to the
lightning network
so
good well i was going to ask so when you
think about that lightning network uh
you've got a bunch of charts here what's
your before we get into the graphics
what's your general thought process
around the lightning network at the
moment is this something that people
should really be paying attention to or
is it still too early to get overly
excited about it
i think i think it's huge right like
you're seeing what jackson you had jack
on last week and you know
this is completely changing uh
you know
how we do things like you know you look
at countries where they don't have
access to banking um you know you look
at remittances and how that's changed
things for countries you know like el
salvador for example um you know i think
i think the lightning network is just
crucial in general for
transitioning bitcoin from uh you know
predominantly a store of value we talk
about bitcoin is is the most efficient
way to move value across uh space and
time right that's from safety dean's uh
the bitcoin standard but the lightning
network helps helps us transition to
more of that medium medium of exchange
right we talk about you know you go from
like collectibles to store value medium
of exchange to unit of account and so
the lightning network will although
still young you know eventually help us
make that transition and i think at some
point you won't even know you're
interacting with the lightning network
um and you know it's it's
you know from being being just a
bitcoiner you know it's it's really cool
to see like what's what jack did with
twitter and what's going on in el
salvador and seeing you know lightning
network in like starbucks and mcdonald's
i think it's still early days but you're
seeing you know i think you're just
starting to kind of hit that s curve in
terms of lightning adoption
when we look at these charts on
lightning itself one piece that seems to
just kind of jump out to me is the
channel size uh the number of channels
even the number of nodes these are only
the public numbers right this is only
the channels and nodes that we know of
is there an idea as to what the
non-public size is is it 30 bigger 50
percent what's kind of your take on that
i think that's a great question i just
don't know um i don't know either
yeah maybe there's been like a a study
or someone's put out like a little
research paper on it but yeah i i
haven't i haven't heard anything about
you know how we how you would even go
about estimating that um maybe maybe
some of the guys that like lightning
laps would know
yeah i i don't know what the answer is
the number that i've heard and again
this is like literally i heard from
somebody who heard from somebody was
somewhere between 25 to 30
of the network is not in public channels
or publicly uh uh addressable nodes but
you know who knows what that number
could be my guess is it's not one
percent and it's not double right it's
probably some somewhere in between there
even if we are we're you know we're
looking at you know like five six
thousand btc of capacity so you know
it's it's it's still very very tiny
agreed let's talk about miners uh we
were just talking about uh michael
saylor had these a couple of comments
about uh miners putting much more of uh
what they're producing into storage
rather than selling on open market is
the on-chain metric showing uh pretty
much the same thing
i'm sorry i missed like the first part i
put out a bit but talk to us about the
miners in terms of hash rate difficulty
and then what they're doing with uh the
bitcoin that they're producing
got it yeah sure so let's go ahead the
last chart um this is you'll see in
orange is is the hash and then blue is
difficulty
and so
the difficulty adjustment was one of
satoshi's you know uh most innovative
creations in my opinion because it's
essentially you know pegging issuance to
uh
the energy securing the network and so
whenever whenever you have hash come on
the network you have a positive
difficulty adjustment whenever you see
hash moving off the network you have a
negative difficulty adjustment and so
the last time we had five um you know
consecutive positive difficulty
adjustments um was early 2020 in like
january february time frame we had four
earlier this year uh but yeah the last
time we had five was was early 2020 so
this is just another way to look at as
you can see in the with the orange line
uh hash is coming back on the network uh
we had that you know huge chinese minor
migration you're now starting to see
that that hash get plugged in elsewhere
around the world um and so yeah i'm
bullish hash
it it feels like we are uh back in
business hashrate is coming back
aggressively uh joe and john what
questions do you guys have in terms of
what's going on right now bill uh well i
mean uh bill
hill i was reading something about it
damn joe
hey will hey will man i got you he's
fired no problem fire joe hey bill
well uh my my question uh is about kind
of what you look at outside of on chain
metrics so um we've seen a lot of price
action especially in the equity markets
and and uh debt markets as well do you
spend any time looking at that relative
to the onsha metrics or do you only uh
focus on kind of what's happening in
bitcoin and think there's no kind of
correlation
no they're definitely correlated um
it it's just funny though like sometimes
we go through this spurious like really
heavily correlation heavy correlations
and then obviously if you're like a
liquidity crunch like all correlations
you know are gonna you know come
together but
um
i i have been watching you know
obviously the sby and the dxy lately
over the last couple months or so um you
have seen some strong correlation there
partially because you've had a lot of
this you know macro uncertainty so
you've just seen in general um you know
like some some risk off behavior we saw
that with the whole evergreen thing
aside from aside from that you know i
keep an eye on those things you know
like i wake up in the morning check the
dixie see the s p or the s p futures um
you know check ten year
um
and then i you know in terms of in terms
of like technical indicators i look at
you know just basic oscillators like rsi
um
you know i just look for basic
divergences and stuff i look at price
structure just you know very very
general levels i don't draw like 20
million lines on the screen but you know
i just draw some important levels that i
think
you know bitcoins interacted with over
the last couple months um and then i
like i mentioned earlier i look at the
you know the order books so i use
trading light which is a great platform
it's just a heat map of all the bids and
asks and then lastly and this is
probably the most the thing i check most
often
is the derivatives data so i look at you
know the funding rate across all
different exchanges
and then also the the futures basis and
then open interest as well uh because
you know derivatives data affects the
price in the short term is along with
price structure whereas on chain is more
tracking the broader trends so if you
want to you know look at perhaps what's
going to happen over the next couple
days next few hours you know look at
that derivatives data and also you know
shorter term price structure you can you
know oscillators too you know like if
rsi is is way overbought or oversold
basic things like that
john what questions you got big dog
what's up will nice mic nice headphones
great good setup you got there
um so i'm curious going into q4 what are
the big movers are going to be here is
it all going to be just based off the
supply on the exchanges like how do you
think about it and then
when and if this bitco this bull run
ends when when do you see that happening
yeah i think like you know we've been
we've been tracking a lot of these
supply dynamics for a while and we'll
start to see them come into fruition
where you know over the next couple
months we've been talking about since
summer that we'll probably see them come
into fruition later this year into maybe
january of next year
um as far as like the the ending of of
the bull market i mean i had no idea
you know like going off of historical
four-year cycles then perhaps you're
looking at december january
um also you know you have like tax you
know people selling bitcoin for tax
purposes at the end of the year
um but it's it's hard to say like you
know i'm just going to follow the data
and whenever the the data starts
flipping bearish like i'll flip bearish
if you start to see you know a bunch of
coins um you know moving on to exchanges
see coins becoming liquid so you see old
guy you know older coins really just
uh dumping so you see whales dumping um
you know those kinds of things
but
for now you know i'm just following
following the trend man that's it's i i
don't really know i i would say end of
year to to the beginning of next year
just based off like these historical
four-year cycles but
as we as we mentioned earlier you know
i i i'm starting to kind of move away
from the camp that we operate in these
four-year cycles i think over time um
this is like a whole nother discussion
we can have but i think bitcoin starts
to become more free-floating um you know
not saying that we don't have any
drawdowns but i think
you know we move away from that very
pretty you know cup structure every four
years and you look at bitcoin on like a
logarithmic chart
yeah that's a good point about the uh
taxes as well at the end of the year
will
what's going on with college life are
you still on campus just uh not going to
class
yeah i'm just vibing man
we're going to send you one of these
shirts you can't vibe unless you got a
best business show miami edition shirt
you're going to need one of those i know
that north carolina gets a little cold
but it's always summer in miami so when
you're wearing it it's just you just
bring your mind to somewhere nice and
warm on the beach
yeah you send it to me i'll wear it on
the show for sure
i need you wearing that at uh the
darties there on saturdays
[Music]
john what you know about dardy's i know
a little bit he's been doing a couple
yeah you've been to i went to college no
i haven't been to ecu maybe i'll come
visit you well we'll do a show me and
you and then we'll we'll zoom in with
them
we'll have will and john live reporting
from
[Laughter]
you know you know that meme and it's
like the guy in the club like whispering
whispering to the girl and yeah that's
like really you know
we need to make one and it's like super
bounced off one
[Laughter]
will what are your friends are they are
they getting on board now are they more
excited that uh that you dropped out and
uh bitcoin they're getting excited about
it or they still think you're crazy
no i mean they don't think i'm crazy
like
i think a lot of them a lot of them just
buy bitcoin because they're like oh he
must know what he's talking about kind
of thing but a lot of my buddies are
interested in it you know it's just they
want to know what i even do
um you know i i teach them i teach them
a little bit about like the on-chain
stuff but for the most part you know
they just
you know they buy a little bit hold it
you know and i got the marge filled a
bit
i love it i love it um all right i just
put into the chat uh will's twitter
account so make sure that you guys all
go follow them i mean you just been
dropping bombs on people non-stop it
seems like uh so keep up the great work
um anything that you want to leave leave
the people with in terms of uh what
you're thinking about kind of moving
forward
i mean i don't know i just think it's
going to be exciting next couple months
um you know keep your eyes peeled i
think we've we've seen some you know
strong accumulation
um
over the you know the last couple months
especially since like you know july 20th
27th 28th so like very end of july um
perhaps maybe we'll start to see some of
those buyers stick their neck out and
say who they are um i remember you know
we had we had sailor announced and that
was all on the on-chain data guys i
forget the numbers but you know i
remember i put out a tweet two weeks ago
maybe it was just saying you know we've
been tracking whales have bought x
amount of coins right like that was in
the data that sailor bought and whatever
he bought i forget exactly how much but
you know there's
he bought a fraction in terms of what
we've seen whales buying and
you know who those people are maybe
maybe we'll find out over the next
couple months
um so there's a little hopium opium for
the audience but uh yeah guys i hope you
have a great weekend and thanks for
having me on as always whenever you want
to come to ecu i got you what's up guys
bang bang thanks so much for watching
the best business show today if we're
gonna be the best business show we
obviously need the best partner that's
why the exclusive sponsor the best
business show is sofi they're an
all-in-one platform that allows you to
invest in all kinds of different assets
including stocks etfs crypto ipos and
they even have an automated investing
function if that's your thing so before
we start getting after it again make
sure that you go download sofi you get
an invest account and when you make your
first crypto trade regardless of what
you buy they'll give you 10 in bitcoin
for free it's that simple head on over
to sofi.com to get started today thanks
so much for watching and i hope you come
back and watch more the best business
show tomorrow
[Music]
you